continuing where we left off last week
with the chapter
that if
has put in place
for the
reasons causes
of a person's heart being opened to the
quran and sunnah
first thing that he listed was a tawhid
and this is the longest and most
extensive part of what we're going to be
speaking about inshallah
[Silence]
foreign
so
the first thing that he mentions here is
that
we mentioned the types of shirk last
week
we want to mention the types of tohit
right
i want you to think of tohid and shirk
as night and day
okay
i want you to think of the mushrik and
the
muslim or muahid as the blind
and the seeing
i want you to think of them as the deaf
and the one who can hear
[Silence]
the parable of the two groups the people
of paradise and the people of hell
fundamentally
is that of the blind and deaf and
the one who can see and hear
i want you to think of taheed
and i want you to think of shirk as
night and day
now
i want you to think of tohit and shirk
as night and day
they could be no no more opposite
yet
one can creep into the other
correct
one can creep into the other but
wherever the day time comes even a
sliver of it
it will remove the darkness correct
and wherever the nighttime comes in even
a sliver of it will remove the light and
the daytime from that area in that place
now imagine your heart
your actions your deeds
your life
your relationship with allah
as the entire sky as both horizons
you want to keep both of those horizons
with the sun directly in the center of
the sky
that is complete to heed
now that is the furthest you can be from
the darkness
correct
and the
more
the sun is
less
prevalent
the more
prevalent ashik will be in a person's
life
we have to look at the quran as a book
that is
very
concise allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
sent down the quran
to be concise enough for us to be able
to memorize it and implement it
but this book
had a lot of qualities
and a lot of conditions
number one the quran had to contain all
of the relevant information from the
previous books of allah
that's number one
number two it had to be the most concise
meaning it had to say the most with as
little words
okay
number three
this book the quran
it had to be able to be something that
will be used by humanity as a guide to
allah for the rest of time
until the day of resurrection
for thousands of years possibly
okay
and it has to go around all of the world
to all of the cultures in all situations
and circumstances
and it has to transcend all languages
and customs
and it has to find the commonality of
the human heart in every one of us
that's a lot of conditions to be put on
one book
correct
let's review that for a second
the quran has to be number one
concise
what does that mean concise
it has to say the most with the least
words correct
number two it has to be comprehensive
meaning that everything relevant
from the previous nations from the time
of adam all the way till now of the
teachings of god to mankind has to be
contained in this book
number three
this book has to last
for thousands of years
number four it has to be for all of the
people in all places in all times
which means that the quran has to
transcend rise above
language culture
circumstance
okay
the quran has to go into any place any
culture any mind any human being
no matter where you're from you're from
philistine you're from bosnia you're
from falsely and you're from jordan
you're from egypt you're from right
you're from america it has to come into
your mind no matter what time or place
you're from
and it has to find the commonality in
you which is your
bare bones humanity and change you the
same way it changed the prophet
do you understand the gravity of this
book
that is what the quran has to do
okay
in order for that to happen
the quran has to be
general enough
to where it can apply to anyone
but specific enough to where it can
guide everyone
do you understand
you guys with me here on this
so the quran has to be general enough to
where it can apply to any place anytime
any person
but it has to be specific enough at the
same time
that it will guide every single person
to allah subhanahu wa
this is the quran
and so in the quran
because of these qualities that the
quran has
in order to understand it you have to
understand why it speaks the way it
speaks
okay
usually the quran speaks of two types of
people what are those types of people
huh
the men will cather the believer and the
disbeliever right that's usually what it
is
the worst of disbelievers
and the best of believers that's what
the quran usually speaks about right
when allah uses the word al-mu'min he's
speaking about the person that has
reached the best and highest level of
iman
and when he speaks about the kafir he's
speaking about the lowest level of
kuffar
correct
foreign
and he uses these parables the darkness
and the light seeing and blindness
hearing and deafness
this is how the quran works
now why doesn't allah be more specific
what about someone who is a believer but
commits a lot of sins
right
what about someone who believes in allah
but is a person that is also someone
who's falling very short so they've
mixed good and bad deeds
what about a person who's the opposite
he's a disbeliever but he's not as bad a
disbeliever as those who fight against
allah and his messenger
now those things are mentioned in the
quran but they're not dwelled upon
right
there's mention of them
but they're not dwelled upon usually
what's dwelled upon is the two polar
opposites
why is that
why is the quran so black and white
well the reason for this
is like
painting
you know painting
when you want to make colors
there are things called primary colors
do you know what those are
right
there are primary colors
a painter has primary colors
so he has for example red and he has
yellow or he whatever the primary colors
are okay
and so from those colors he can make any
other color he wants
mashy
so if i take for example
green
and red and i mix them together what am
i going to get
huh
green and red
is it brown
i thought it was purple i don't know
greg
i'm not a painter whatever brown it's
going to be brown if i take black and
white what am i going to have
gray if i take so i have these opposite
colors they're different colors they're
they're fundamentally different
right
but when i mix them okay
i'm going to have different colors come
out of them and i can make any shade and
any color that i want from those primary
colors
do you understand
this is what the quran does
it gives you primary colors
okay
it gives you the polar opposites
and based on how strong this one is or
how strong this one is you can find
every single human being's description
in the quran exactly
exactly
so if you look for yourself in the quran
you will find your description exactly
in the quran
every single one of us
is described in the quran
if we look for those descriptions and
take the right mixture your exact
description is in the quran
so i want you to think of
the first element of the quran which is
still hidden shirk
i want you to think of them as day and
night black and white
okay
now
there are people who are people of
tawheed but they have elements of shirk
and there are people of shirk that have
elements of tawheed do you understand
everybody has imagined this with me
good
now we can speak about tawheed and shirk
tahid is two types
just we said shirk is what
two types
likewise tahid is two types
the first type of taheed
is
[Silence]
so we have two types of tawheed and two
types of shirk
okay
two types of tohit
tell hate of belief
and tawheed of actions worship
okay
we have two types of shirk
we have major shirk
and we have minor shirk
let's start with the tohit
because in order for us to completely
understand to heed we have to understand
it's opposite as well this is why we
study shirk
okay
so
the toheid of belief or the torheed of
knowledge
or the to hate in the arabic language
literally translates to making something
one
okay
and what is it
it is making allah one in our beliefs
what does that mean making him one in
our beliefs meaning making him one in
everything that is specific to him
not having anyone else or anything else
have any of his attributes or names or
actions
okay that is an issue of belief correct
who is the only creator
who is the only one who
maintains that creation allah
subhanahu ta'ala who is the only
sovereign king of that creation and
owner of all that is created and exists
this is belief of
and some scholars refer to it as
this is the first type of tohit
the second type of tahid
is
all of them are used by the scholars
okay
what is
it is
that
of allah
in your actions
what does that mean in your actions
the worship of allah alone without any
partners
everything that is worship is for allah
and allah alone without any partners
this is called
all of them are
correct these are two types of tohit
now listen really closely to this
principle i'm gonna give you now
okay
you with me
[Silence]
what does that mean
the principle is as follows
the first type of tawheed
to heed of belief
it necessitates
taheed of actions
and the tahiti of actions to hid
entails tawheed
of belief
let me repeat it
memorize it
learn it
this is an important principle of
understanding the quran
the heed of belief
necessitates to heed of
action no heed of action to
entails
to heed of belief
okay
now we're gonna now that we've memorized
the principle we're gonna explain it
okay what does that mean
what it means is that
if you believe let's start with the
first half
the first story type of tohit tohito
to heed of belief necessitates
the talheed of actions meaning if you
have to heed of belief to hate of
actions is gonna have to be there too
okay what does that mean
that means if you believe that allah is
the only creator
or the allah is the only sustainer
or that allah is the only one that can
give and the only one that can truly
take and the only one that can truly
harm and the only one that can truly
help
then that necessitates by logic the next
logical step is that you would what
worship only
allah correct
of allah's actions
necessitates
to heed of worship of allah alone
without any partners
if you believe in this then you must
believe in this and that is the argument
of the prophets
all of the prophets and the messengers
that's what they came and said
right
they all came and said
who has created the heavens and the
earth allah who is the one who sustains
you allah who is the one who protects
protects you and no one can protect you
from him allah then why don't you
worship allah
that is the argument of all of the
prophets throughout the entirety of the
quran
right
now let's go to the other half
to
what does that mean
meaning it includes it
right
so when you worship something
you're only worshipping it because you
believe that it can either harm or help
the only reason that we worship is we
worship because we are trying to
flee from harm
and
attain help
whatever that is
and so when you worship allah
it goes to stand that that warship
includes that you believe allah is the
only one that can help you
correct or not
this is very important
because
any time
the
mushrikeen
those who worship other than allah
worship in any way other than a law
it comes with a belief system
it comes with a belief that other than
allah has some of the attributes of
allah
you understand that
huh and for example
if someone goes to a grave
and prays to whatever willie
okay
or whatever person is in the grave or
whatever saint in catholicism or
whatever idol an idolatry or
whatever god in hinduism or
whatever it is
when they go and pray to that person or
thing
they are praying because they believe
that that person or thing has some of
the attributes of allah
you understand do you understand how
they're entwined
right
the mushrikeen that the prophets and
messengers came to
believe the first but didn't believe the
second
okay
so they would
believe that yes allah is the only
creator however
other than allah
will intercede on our behalf
and some of the attributes of allah
belong to these idols that we worship
this was their belief
that these idols had the ability these
people or these idols or the they had
the ability to
influence allah even against his own
will
and this is why allah said mandela is
claiming
that is going to force his intercession
upon allah who is this
it's a rhetorical question nobody
forces his intercession upon allah
[Silence]
the point here
that we're making
is that
of belief
and ship
they are intertwined
one logically leads to the other and one
logically includes the other
you cannot separate them
okay
so
the first type of tohit
this involves what
allah's names
correct
allah's attributes
and allah's actions
three things
so heat of belief
we believe in allah's what
names
attributes
and
actions
correct
names
allah
tells us about his names and attributes
the second are his attributes
what are his attributes
i want you to
imagine with me a bullseye
can you imagine a bullseye
you have a circle in the middle and then
you have a bigger circle out here okay
the bullseye the one in the middle
that is the names of allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
okay
that
includes
his attributes
so any name of allah
we take an attribute and an action from
it
you understand we have a bullseye so if
it's in the middle it's also in the
bigger circle as well
but the second circle i want you to
imagine as being the attributes of allah
meaning that not every attribute we take
a name from it
you get what i'm saying let's take an
example
the name of allah
okay
that's the name of allah right
where is that on our bullseye
which circle
in the center the smallest one the one
that includes all of them why
because
he is
so we have a name
from that name we derive an attribute
which is
so he is the merciful we derive an
attribute which is mercy
and then we derive another which is
actions
which is a bigger circle and that is
what
the act of giving mercy correct
right
but now let's take an attribute of allah
an attribute of allah like
we're speaking
isn't speaking an attribute of allah
he speaks correct
he speaks to the prophet muslim he spoke
to the angels he speaks to jibril he
speaks to whoever he chooses etc right
is that a name of allah so that's in
which one of our circles
the second one right
that is the
that is the attribute of allah
we do not do the opposite we don't take
a name from the attribute
the attribute only articulates that
that's his attribute and then we take
from the attribute and action
right
so we say
his attribute is speaking
and he his action is speech
okay
but we don't take a name from that and
call him the speaker the all-speaking
subhanahu
[Silence]
is
so when we talk about the names and
attributes of allah we're talking about
imagine that bullseye with me again
the center of the bullseye is the
all-inclusive it includes all three
rings right
it includes the name the attribute and
the action
anything at the center of that bullseye
is a name
we take from that name
attributes and actions
but anything that is in the second and
not in the bullseye we take only actions
from
right
and anything that is in the actions we
do not take an attribute from
so for example
let's say
that
[Silence]
is
if we understand this issue of taheed we
will understand its opposite of shirk
so what are the types of tahid
two types of tohit correct
the first type is toheed
all of them are correct
which means
belief in the
names
attributes and actions of allah
subhanahu wa
correct
where what is the source of the names
and attributes and actions of
quran and allah correct
but there are some logical
things that we can learn about allah by
observation of his actions correct
am i correct or not
tell me if i'm incorrect
so for example if i am observing
rain comes down and greenery comes up
and life flourishes
can i not logically conclude that allah
is merciful
what's the answer to this
yes i can logically conclude that is
that not right
[Silence]
there are logical things that i can use
my brain and my mind
to know about allah
for example knowledge
right
could all of this been created without
knowledge
no
could all of this have been created
without ability
no therefore logically these things are
affirmed for allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
but there are other things which we
learn only by the way of the quran and
sunnah
right
for example
a
is
[Silence]
is this something that my mind can
logically take me to no i need the quran
and sunnah to inform me of this
right
so
it's kind of the laws of allah
right
logically
i can say
lying is wrong stealing is wrong murder
is wrong inflicting unnecessary pain is
wrong right
making someone happy is right
telling the truth is right
giving someone who is less fortunate
than myself is right
this is even without a religion i can
know this automatically correct
but then there's other things that
there's no way i can know without
the quran and sunnah correct
like
how to pray
how to express my gratitude to allah
how to repent
logically felt to repent or not
what's the answer
when adam alayhis salaam ate from the
tree
and then
[Silence]
you have to understand
that the mind is a creation of allah
and the mind leads you to allah
some of the scholars of islam said a
very profound statement
they said
the function of the mind is to lead you
to allah
and there it stops
what does that mean
that means that the function of the mind
is to lead you to allah and his book and
his messenger
and at that point
you follow exactly what is in the quran
in sunnah whether your mind understands
it or not whether your mind accepts it
or not
that is the place where the mind ends
and the journey of revelation begins
now
so
in closing
we learned today
about the two types of tohit
we learned that
there is tahit
of allah's actions
oneness of allah's actions
and oneness
of the actions of the servants
correct
oneness in allah's actions meaning his
names attributes and
actions
and oneness in the human beings actions
meaning that we make allah one in our
acts of worship
we learned as well today that everyone
who worships
has a belief system behind that worship
so if you worship allah alone without
any partners that means that you have
believed in allah's names and attributes
completely
if you worship other
another along with allah this means that
you have given some of the attributes of
allah to other than allah
that is why you have worshipped other
than allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala we understand
this is what is tawheed
so last week we learned about a shikh
major and minor this week we learned
about toheid to
next week in sha allah we will discuss
how they interact
right and we're going to discuss people
who have elements of taheed but are
kuffar
and people who have elements of kufur
but are muslim
right
that's what we're going to speak about
next week inshaallah now that we've
spoken about the two complete polar
opposites
of